bienvenue dans paf numéro 6 pas vous le
savez ce sont des débats autour de
l'actualité avec une bande d'ailleurs si
vous voulez nous rejoindre vous pouvez
vous nous contactez puis vous viendrez
ici mais pour l'instant je vous présente
ce qu'ils sont là d'abord une rebelle
qui est descendu dans la rue avec les
avocats qui redescendra peut-être dans
la rue avec les patrons du medef
est-ce qu'elle sonne la révolte des
nantis nous le dire et c'est
d'invocateur au barreau de versailles
florence mercadé pour jour bonjour ça va
bien ça va très bien très bien
l'homme qui sait que l'art de la table
ne serait rien sans l'art de la
conversation qui nous vient tout droit
de la commanderie des templiers c'est
jean-luc madec ça va bien en patrie ça
va très bien celui qui est assez de
morale pour ne pas faire profiter les
footballeurs trappe qu'il préside des
médicaments qu'il vend dans sa pharmacie
c'est mustapha larfaoui bonjour patrie
ça va bien ça va super bien très bien
un garçon qui sait faire bouillir la
marmite mais aussi chauffer la polémique
c'est mustapha sa mort a dit noureddine
amir dernière mais non non non quand
même pas et puis un homme qui ne se
contente pas de parler mais qui sait
aussi faire écrire les autres sanitaire
jean charles lajoie ni et vous publiez
d'ailleurs un livre de l'actualité ce
sont les les rênes au 6 rue des ordures
donc si vous détestez noël dressé du
père noël tout à fait délicieux et
l'attelage de dessins de balle week est
un très bon dessinateur de presse
voilà qu'elle est magnifique et des
couleurs superbes un beau trait d'humour
dont le niveau est parfaite we say die
il ya encore première balle de france
ont fait front
on recommence pas alors bon on va
commencer par une nouvelle de
l'actualité immédiate puisque ça s'est
trouvé il ya peu de tout c'est la
consternation de brandao brandao c'est
l'avant centre de bastia l'ex avant
centre de bastia qui avait mis un coup
de tête à thiago motta lors du match
bastia psv et il vient d'être condamné à
un an ferme un mois un mois ferme moyens
mois ferme on va faire le progrès avait
demandé huit mois avec sursis je crois
il a été condamné à un mois ferme et la
prison ferme ça vous ça vous appelle
quelques commentaires charme si c'est
absolument scandaleux com de com
décision
rien ne justifie ça on passe son temps à
juste titre parfois à dire qu'il faut
pas
embastillé à tour de rôle hélas ce type
qui s'est bagarré enfin je veux dire
c'est un truc assez commun notre avis
nous le dira dans le foot fallu c'est
pas du tout bien ce qu'il a fait je suis
d'accord mais ça ça nous sommes des six
titres en aucun cas à mois de prison
ferme et avec à le condamner une énorme
amende et il est plein aux as ils
pouvaient payer
et puis le faire jouer avec des
footballeurs c'est pas par exemple avec
les footballeurs de du football club de
trappes il aurait appris on n'accepte
pas les voyous à côte il a joué à jouer
au football sur été très bien et puis à
ce compte là si on met vraiment brandao
un mois en prison
zidane fallait le mettre deux ans en
prison mais si c'est parce que c'était
prémédité
vainqueur ce sont les mêmes injures
chaque l'amour pour vous c'est trop
jean-luc standard s'est passé vraiment
ferme au minimum sud était sous la
révolution c'était la guillotine il est
clair que l'exemple que doivent donner
les joueurs professionnels du égard la
position qu'ils ont vers le grand public
et surtout vers le public jeune doit
être absolument bien maîtrisé si ces
gens ne sont pas capables de se
maîtriser
faut pas qu'ils aillent dans les équipes
internationales faut qu'ils restent dans
les communes la haute vienne
mais à un mois c'est insuffisant
clairement clairement il ya aujourd'hui
dans une société qui malheureusement ne
va pas bien
un exemple à donner et il est clair que
ces gens doivent donner l'exemple moral
il supporte tout d'accord avec jean luc
la situation la situation dans laquelle
on trouve est assez cocasse c'est à dire
que jean-luc voudrait que les
footballeurs soient les exemples c'est
un de nos enfants et que ce soit les
footballeurs la bourgeoisie
d'intelligence exceptionnel qu'ils
soient justement l'exemple pour les
gamins moi je pense que les footballeurs
sont des hommes comme les autres c'est
pas parce qu'ils gagnent de l'argent ou
qui sont exposés qui doivent être plus
exemple on rêvait dans la mer ils font
rêver mais un mois la question qu'on
doit poser c'est est ce que quelqu'un
nombre d'ânes importe qui met un coup de
tête jusqu'à casser le nez d'une
personne lambda dans la rue est-ce qu'il
prend un mois de prison ferme ou pas et
ce qui devait le prendre
voilà nous savoir ce qui curieusement
n'a ce débat aujourd'hui avec brandao
on a beau me réserve la parole de la
faim à l'avocate le match est donc
probable la place du procureur de
l'avocat budget rajustement quand on met
un coup de tête dans la réaction combien
de temps je disais je disais oui vous
téléphonez vouloir céder parce que c'est
le brésilien joue à marseille il n'y a
pas eu l'heur odienne et donc oui il ya
un débat aujourd'hui et brandao y en a
pas eu existant à l'époque moi je me
souviens d'un final d'accident le monde
je me suis en finale coupe du monde
j'avais été interviewé par canal plus ce
qu'ils étaient venus voir le match
auprès des joueurs de trappes
j'avais été interviewé à la fin du match
donc ça existe les images existent
j'avais dit que ça vite et scandaleux
mais c'était hogan s'était dit là d'où
le scandale de ce qu'est ce qu'on va le
secteur it and bass qui les mutilés mis
un coup de tête
ce qui est d'autant plus scandaleux
c'est qu'on n'en avait pas parlé à
l'époque c'est à dire que globalement le
lendemain était à l'elysée même s'il a
félicité reçu par chirac le lendemain
féliciter parce que l'équipe de france
méritait d'être félicité à ce moment là
sauf que pour le coup de boule n'y a pas
eu ce débat maintenant faire revenir
maintenant maintenant pour revenir sur
le débat d'aujourd'hui
jean charles a raison pardon jean-luc à
a raison sur un point c'est que moi je
connais pas les remplaçants celle
d'alain les autres je les connais pas
comme des raisins mais voilà il a raison
de dire que donc ils sont là mais c'est
une sanction qui doit être exemplaire
parce que clermont contrairement à ce
que dit jean charles sais que tu as
l'air de banaliser ce qui se passe dans
les terrains ça arrive tous les
week-ends probablement que ce week-end
il faut surtout uniquement celle là pour
orienter pas de coup de boule pendant un
match cela il attend le type à la sortie
d'un éphèbe édité par ea les mets un
coup de boule incessamment j'ai donc
choisi ce bar après il se barre après
voilà donc c'est pas tout à fait dans
l'action semble avait fait dix dames je
me dis bien qu'on vous parlez de choses
mais ça ne fait pas ça arrive à la fois
sur les terrains savent alex thériault
terrain face à elle sur les parkings et
des matches de foot et c'est en ça que
je dis que c'est vrai que ça existe mais
faut pas le banaliser pour autant et se
dire que si ça arrivait que le monde ça
peut avec les professionnels non salle
on repart avec les professionnels je
pense que cette campagne c'est l'avocate
l'avocate la marque a donc toujours en
défense mais je trouve qu'à mois ferme
soit pas beaucoup de sens en termes de
compréhension de la peine
dire qu'une peine pénale elle doit être
adapté à la personnalité de la personne
qui est jugé et elle doit être comprise
et là en l'espèce il faut qu'elle soit
comprise
au delà de brandao parce qu'il ya les
petits joueurs de foot de trappes et de
marteaux et je pense que ce qui serait
important c'est que la justice passe
aussi le message assez je suis assez
d'accord sur le fait de dire que brandao
il doit aussi véhicules image vis-à-vis
des jeunes fauteurs d'autres peines il
ya des peines alternatives que là dessus
on doit être sur une peine alternative
qui est maintenant les une amende
pourquoi pas parce que effectivement
beaucoup d'argent mais surtout du
travail d'intérêt général d'aller dans
des petits clubs de fonds structurés de
et qui viennent expliquer que ce qu'il a
fait c'est pas bien aussi qu'ils
viennent dire j'aurais pas dû geler
explora et qu'on ait quelque chose qui
soit pédagogique pour brandao si on peut
mais en tout cas pour le pour les autres
autre petit matin
et les matches parce qu'il a une sale
image aussi dans une sale image d'être
un joueur qui met des coups de coude
l'émail et il a payé pour viol la bce
n'a pas été donc non mais peut-être
cycle environnement rentrer tout cet
environnement voit le sien je ne connais
pas c'est ça peut rentrer aussi à la
peine
je ne sais pas derrière toi sangatte
réservé aux idoles bien dire que pour
ceux qui ont fait du foot en tout cas
quand on est dans le match et c'est pas
le prêt à se battre
le fait n'est pas la même chose
d'attendre carrément le second d'un
match s'est aggravée après le viol
aggravé mais sur le terrain c'est pareil
je suis en souvenez vous ça va c'est pas
bien c'est pas bien si c'est par de
prendre un peu plus urgent est dans
l'humeur j'ai beaucoup de gens viennent
chez nous qui sont en stage ou en
apprentissage
donc on les côtoie et viennent de
trappes ils viennent de d'elancourt de
maurepas et quand ils sont en demande de
sport et notamment de foot et
gouvernement mais qu'est ce qui te
motive dans le foot
ils vous répondent la thune et ça c'est
grave
et à partir du moment où un jeune rêve
de faire un sport d'équipé notamment du
football et mustapha le sait très bien
il les côtoie lui aussi au quotidien qui
rêvent d'argent ouais bon sens le sport
c'est pas l'argent on en a parlé lors de
notre dernier entretien
juste pour dire que l'attitude est
beaucoup plus importante parfois que
tout ce qu'on peut dire autour de cette
table juste l'attitude des adultes
vis-à-vis des enfants
l'attitude et savoir se tenir donc c'est
important de nage alors retardé
d'actualité c'est le projet de najat
vallaud belkacem mise de l'éducation
nationale de remplacer on sera six a
lieu au mois de janvier
remplacer les notes barre des couleurs c
est qu on aura plus 0 mais rouge viendra
plus vers 18 mai vers qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
non khadija vous fait rire voyais pas
trop je comprends pas trop ce débat en
plus on aurait pu s'inspirer des
d'autres pays qui l'ont déjà essayé de
2,7 essayant le danemark le québec qui
est revenue ensuite dessus
comment il faut bien valider une
connaissance à l'école il faut bien
qu'on sache où se trouve ou s'ils lui
avaient cédé à mon ordi est moins gras
moins bon mais c'est moins clair moi je
trouve à à -1 pb - et c'est pas la plus
importante dans cette ce qui est plus
important cent cinquante mille jeunes
quand même qui sortent chaque année de
l'école sans diplôme un diplôme si on me
dit qu'ils en arrivent à me convaincre
que sa cause des notes un mois pour la
france je n'y vois pas de lien c'est
peut-être dans les méthodes
d'apprentissage le nombre de profs
stands dans les liens qu il ya pire que
ça je pense que madame vallaud-belkacem
seraient inspirés de regarder quel est
le rapport des gens qui sont dans
l'administration à l'éducation nationale
par rapport à ceux qui sont sur le
terrain dans les classes le nombre
d'administrés d'être dans ce passionnant
l'éducation nationale a triplé ces dix
dernières années ce qui veut dire qu'on
a de moins en moins de gens sur le
terrain dans les classes et de plus en
plus dans les bureaux à contrôler ce
qu'ils font on travaille dans les
classes donc il faut là que l'éducation
nationale se remettre un petit peu à
jour et refasse descendre les gens qui
sont dans les bureaux dans les classes
et vous allez voir que ça aide beaucoup
après la notion de couleur que mon lit
tous on va faire du vert pâle du bien
foncier doit se laver de quoi faudrait
un truc assez amusant ce qui est plus la
société dure plus on essaye de préserver
les enfants de herri de cette dureté
soit si un jour on n'était pas notre et
les autres s'éloignent tellement de la
réalité mais c'est valable et l'incident
tous les sujets il faut s'attaquer une
fois de plus est ce qu'on ne fait pas de
manière assez rituel enfants s'attaquer
au fond on a non à la sortie de zone 2
on a 20 % aux gamins qui savent pas lire
qui savent pas bien écrire et 30% de
gamins à la sortie de scène deux qui
sont pas bons en maths et qui ont pas
intégrer les problématiques de calcul
alors je sais c'est pas parce qu'on aura
du rouge du vert aux yeux pour son goût
des couleurs ce que savent pas lire
donc si on s'attaque au fond disant il
faut accompagner les enfants et ont fait
plus de soutien scolaire et on essaye de
peut-être pas de les noter pour les
encourager en disant parce qu'on a eu de
moi mes gamins quand il était à l'école
maternelle c'était acquis nana qui en
cours d'acquisition et c'est essayer de
les aider là dessus mais avec un vrai
soutien au fonds dans la classe et pas
parce qu'on est en cours d'acquisition
et si on est pas le gamin derrière à
acquérir on va c'est toujours en cours
d'acquisition et on sera toujours rouge
donc c'est plus d'annoncés sur leflux
des actifs dans les classes et -
d'administration de même que je maîtrise
un peu plus c'est celui de la santé
c'est vrai que par exemple pour prendre
la température quand quelqu'un est
malade on a tendance à prendre un terme
au met et à vérifier la note de 37 et
gratuite s'effectue à 38 39
c'est vrai que des thermomètres qui sont
de couleur donc maintenant le même pour
la température on met un thermomètre
frontale et on ne lit plus le 37 5 et 38
on regarde la couleur et l on va sur
annabac bref c'est un peu la même chose
dire que chacun aura 1 à bac la bac sera
peut-être différent demain d'une
académie à l'autre et on ira chercher
des couleurs et la bourrée correspond à
un chiffre pour faire simple au revoir
et comparaisons
en train de casser le thermomètre pour
faire 5 dollars payés la baleine alors
je vais vous nous avez peut-être de
donner une note qu'aucun une couleur sur
saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
réussite est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un échec en tout cas jean paul
alduy qui est devenu par la suite maire
député maire de perpignan qui a été le
premier directeur de de saint quentin en
yvelines était là il ya quelques jours
vient de publier un livre et il raconte
ses souvenirs sur la création de saint
quentin en yvelines
on le regarde on en parle après
jean-paul à lui n'était jamais revenu à
saint quentin en yvelines une
agglomération qui l'a quittée en 1993 il
était alors directeur général de
l'établissement public d'aménagement
vingt ans plus tard celui que l'on
appelait zébulon en raison de son
énergie à faire les choses est revenu à
saint quentin en yvelines pour y
présenter son dernier ouvrage non sans
émotion une sorte de pudeur à revenir
sur un territoire que j'avais quitté et
où s'était achevé ma vie de
fonctionnaire d'état de techniciens de
la ville
c'est au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'il est venu
rencontrer ses anciens collègues et amis
il se souvient que le théâtre n'a jamais
été terminé normalement sur la façade du
théâtre dans les petites mains des
hommes que vous voyez de vie voire des
statuts il manque des statuts sur cette
façade il manque toujours un jour que
que l'on met dans chacune de ces niches
une statue tel que c'était prévu dans le
premier projet autre souvenir fort le
technocentre renault à guyancourt sa
dernière décision la vente des terrains
la régie renault une histoire
surprenante
ça a démarré par quelqu'un dont je
tairai le nom qui est venu me voir dans
mon petit pigeonnier 2b loyer de la
ferme de mes moyens et qui m'a dit je
peux pas vous dire qui je suis je peux
pas vous dire quelle société jeu
je suis mais j'ai besoin de 300 hectares
et je sais pour produire 300 400 500 600
mille mètres carrés on sait pas que ça
fait ça fait drôle quand quelqu'un vous
dit un charlatan c'était sérieux et je
pouvais même pas donné le nom de
l'entreprise à roland nadeau il fallait
qu'ils me fassent confiance
et oui parce que on est entre nous le
projet la régie renault
si ces bruits des c'était des grèves le
regard que jean paul alduy porte
aujourd'hui sans la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
dithyrambique sans autre forme de
réserve il parle d'un exemple unique au
monde
il ya des tas de vie nouvelle mais les
autres villes nouvelles sont des
nouvelles essentiellement d'habitat
saint quentin en yvelines a une
puissance économique impressionnante et
voyez une vie nouvelle qui a une telle
puissance économique
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel et je
crois à mon avis que c'est nico moulé
bon tenons brasilia mais brasilia c'est
un autre sujet les gens ne connaissent
mal cinquante années de cinq ans dans
les villes un déficit de notoriété
quand mon avis elle est sous-évalué en
terme de notoriété par rapport à ce que
saint quentin en yvelines est devenu
un dossier malgré tout saint quentin en
yvelines aurait pu aller plus vite selon
jean paul alduy la ville intelligente
cette ville avaient tous les moyens pour
être le laboratoire de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la ville intelligente c'est
à dire la ville qui utilisent toutes ces
nouvelles technologies de la
communication pour faire ensemble que
tout citoyen avec son smartphone sache
exactement ce qu'il a derrière dans le
commerce hausses qui là devant dans
l'hôtel les services publics l'arrivée
du bus les parcs de stationnement la
sécurité de la police et des raies l'a
dit nouvelle aurait pu être la ville
modèle est là la ville exceptionnelle
aujourd'hui on va à fribourg en
allemagne pour voir ça ouais c'est ça on
aurait pu venir à saint quentin en
yvelines
il est bon donc je l'a peut-être que là
mais je m'en suis expliqué avec le
président louvier les obstacles sont
essentiellement des obstacles juridiques
avec les différents opérateurs
d'après ce que j'ai compris mais ça
c'est bien français après saint quentin
en yvelines jean paul alduy a quitté la
fonction territoriale pour s'engager en
politique d'abord maire de perpignan
puis ironie de l'histoire président lui
même d'une communauté d'agglomération il
a dit il d'ailleurs beaucoup appris ici
voilà c'était un sujet avec quand même
les vieux de la vieille parce qu'il veut
un qui dormait non mais c'est les
pionniers votre avis donc plutôt réussit
plutôt plutôt échec
vous allez dire plutôt réussit je suis
sûrement fin bon bah c'est une réussite
puisqu'il le dit et puis on a eu un
arrêt ce qui te dis oui c'est une bonne
chose
triaud c'est une réussite simplement il
ya deux choses dans le reportage c'est
que le technocentre si j'écoute bien
aussi j'ai bien entendu c'est presque le
fruit du hasard conduit quelque chose
d'assez aussi important parce que ça a
été fait comme il le dit et deuxièmement
bas on a bâti quelque chose
donc il ya beaucoup de béton beaucoup de
grues on les a vus mais l'essentiel n'a
pas été fait donc finalement je ne sais
pas si c est ce que aussi on n'est pas
sur des schémas qui sont un peu anciens
ont fait beaucoup de mal à tomber tous
beaucoup et beaucoup de béton on dépense
beaucoup sur les transports en commun
alors que on sait peut-être que d'ici 10
ans les gens se déplaceront plus beauf
chez eux et qu'ils auront des voitures
toutes simples et kidd kidd qui ne
consommeront rien dire ce qu'on veut pas
sûr d'échapper à un peu anciens sur ces
huiles nouvelle quasiment sauvier moi je
suis si je peux me permettre je connais
cette ville est depuis 25 ans je le
restaurant qui est dans la commanderie
la commanderie appartenait talent et à
votre public aménagement et d'ailleurs
c'est le pea et alduy en particulier qui
ont sauvé ce bâtiment qui est le plus
ancien la ville nouvelle
13e siècle ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'à l'époque où la ville nouvelle n'est
elancourt c'est moins de 1000 habitants
c'est près de 30000 aujourd'hui et
finalement quand même la ville nouvelle
grâce à des types brillant comme jean
paul alduy a réussi à sauvegarder à la
fois des notions d'emploi de
développement d'activités
professionnelles industrielles hectares
et en même temps un habitat plutôt de
bonne qualité
et si on compare la ville nouvelle de
saint quentin en yvelines avec cergy
pontoise everyman navale etc
13h51 de ville se porte beaucoup mieux
on le doit à des gens comme jean paul
alduy mais aussi à d'autres élus qui
était le sam d'abord puis la case qui
maintenant et honnêtement ils ont fait
un bon travail alors bien sûr tout est
perfectible mais en même temps que des
sons bien jean paul alduy pour l'avoir
fréquenté pendant de nombreuses années
et pour l'avoir connu ensuite comme
maire de perpignan
doit-il brillant vous êtes installé vous
à moi je suis installé depuis peu de
temps mais territoire non mais je
fréquente le territoire très très
longtemps depuis 1994
donc je connais bien et je pense que
c'est plutôt moi je serais plutôt
d'accord vous dire que c'est une
réussite je sais d'accord avec jean luc
d'abord on a des tas d'entreprises qui
arrive régulièrement et qui s'installe
assez méconnu bling c'est une réussite
économique mans c'est une réussite sans
du logement le plan du logement je crois
qu'il ya un petit souci parce que des
gens quittent un peu le territoire et on
a du mal à attirer de nouveaux habitants
dans le territoire l'on peut être aussi
que le prix du logement a grimpé ce qui
peut être aussi un souci en terme de
prix de
loyers d'habitation mais je pense qu'il
faut mettre un peu
un peu la donne puisqu'il ou le logement
oui alors moi j'habite pas s'arranger
les gerris gvt l'entrée à sa rive du
restaurant là il ya une vie par contre
effectivement parce que c'est la nature
des choses
les commerçants sont très éparpillées on
a essayé de faire centre-ville avec deux
centres comédiens de saint quentin en
yvelines vous avez vu que à côté centre
commercial de skyway c'est un échec
total
ce qui s'est passé un petit peu au tour
a été un peu raté mais là c'est très
utilisé c'est pas des voyants les gens
qui font les bons jours bain très
limpide jean-philippe ce que disent
qu'il faut il faut prévoir très
longtemps la vence des choses qui vont
être un élément qu'est parler et puis on
les agresse d'évolution de l'année six
années cette commune et chacune des sept
commun a cherché à garder aussi sa perf
sg 13 ans d'amour cependant
malheureusement malgré tout je crois que
comparé aux autres villes nouvelles de
bon vivre sur les prés fait bon vivre il
ya d'or ses pairs met au vert une percée
de mer sont sous pression dure un peu
plus longtemps sur ce sujet je sens que
la pente et andré et essai et les
déverse très clair les boules sommaire
français lafarge fait plus que je ne
peux pas juste comparer à d'autres les
nouvelles parce que ça n'a pas beaucoup
de sens la vraie question c'est est ce
qu'on a envie de s'installer mais
d'acheter un appartement ou d'habiter à
50 individus en question les larves sont
fondées ou pas d'accord il ya des villes
nouvelles fantastiques qui a été conçu
par louis xiv qui s'appelle versailles
voilà il y à construire un palais
absolue extraordinaire bien vers ça
évite aux gens maintenant
mais versailles fut une ville nouvelle
et c'est une chose qu'il a créée comme
charles de gaulle créa les villes
nouvelles autour de ça et pour préserver
la qualité a commencé de la même façon
que lui fit lully faisait de la musique
contemporaine à l'époque
on va passer un anniversaire fêté les 30
ans des restos du coeur avec bats
toujours autant de repas servis même de
plus en plus puisque il y en avait de
yann à peu près 6 millions 5
la première année je regarde à 130
millions de servir aujourd'hui le
lancement que justement de la trentième
année des restos du coeur
c'était c'était cette semaine plus de
700 kg de denrées viennent d'être livrés
de l'autre côté la salle d'inscription
pour cette nouvelle campagne ne
désemplit pas dans cette antenne des
restos du coeur 66 bénévoles accueillent
les familles en difficulté notre rôle
c'est de faire en sorte que ne pouvoir
accueillir tous et tous ces gens que ce
soit pour la partie alimentaire que pour
l'aide à la personne bien sûr parce
qu'on ne fait pas que de l'alimentaire
on les aide un peu dans leur démarche
d'un certain un tas de domaines
les restos du coeur lancent leur 30e
campagne d'hiver à rambouillet une
centaine de familles et déjà inscrits
dont une cinquantaine de maires avec
leur bébé en moyenne l'an tel rambo
l'item distribuer 2000 repas par semaine
ici environ une tonne et demie de
nourriture est livrée par semaine les
restos du coeur se bat contre le
gaspillage alimentaire aujourd'hui cela
coûte moins cher aux entreprises de
jeter que de donner aux associations
les stocks qui viennent y viennent
essentiellement des restos bien sûr ils
viennent aussi des collectes que l'on
peut faire il ya une collecte nationale
par an et puis une collecte locale que
l'on organise aussi et puis donc les ce
qu'on appelle nono ramasse dans l'est
dans les magasins
qui veulent bien qu'ils veulent bien
participer à ça lors de la campagne 2013
2014 l'association créée par coluche en
1985 a dépassé pour la première fois le
million de personnes inscrites dans ces
centres et services 130 millions de
repas en france nordine j'ai eu
l'occasion plusieurs fois avec marmite
et femmes d'aller interviewer voilà des
des personnes qui bénéficiaient
justement des services du resto du coeur
est ce qui m'avait frappé c'est le
nombre notamment de retraités de plus en
plus nombreux qui venait à la demande et
des conserves et qu'il faut lui etc
et puis l'augmentation constante des
chiffres aussi avec les pauvres en
france qui représente selon les calculs
entre 5 et 8 millions de personnes
pauvres
bon si on constitution considère que
c'est moins de 830 euros pour vivre
c'est compliqué et puis voilà comment
sortir aussi de 7
est-ce que c'est l'esprit même ce qu'on
s'habitue pas bah on s'habitue forcément
puisque chaque année on nous dit il ya
les restos du corps dos d'homme 100
millions de repas
après l'année d'après 110 millions
l'année d'après 120 millions donc
entendue comme le fait d'ailleurs quand
qu'on va on va attendre d'atteindre les
200 millions et 200 millions de repas
distribués mais c'est une vraie
nécessité
c'est à dire qu'on vous juge pas en
connaissez si coluche était encore là il
aurait mis dedans et voilà bakou l'on
peut lui espérer que ça allait être jugé
quelque chose de vrai que temporaire de
première heure or ce n'est pas le cas il
ya il ya des personnes beaucoup de gens
en france qui ne pourraient pas manger
mais à survivre sans les restos du coeur
donc ça c'est vraiment triste
c'est inquiétant quand on creuse on
creuse le trou
d'année en année et ça ça nous explose à
la figure quand on nous donne les
chiffres
il a maintenant le cagnard et la voilà
et d'état n'a plus d'argent et c'est
vrai que nous alors je faire un tout
petit parallèle par rapport à l'aide
juridictionnelle où il ya de plus en
plus de gens bien lui demande qui
demandent l'aide juridictionnelle parce
qu'ils ont moins en moins de deux
d'argent pour avoir un accès au droit et
donc à plus en plus de gens qui
demandent de l'aide juridictionnelle
avec un budget qui est en train d' et ça
fait partie de nos revendications en
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure mais
avec un budget qui les inquiète de plus
en plus ma où on demande en fait aux
avocats de financer l'aide
juridictionnelle zon fort qu'on donne de
l'argent pour pouvoir avoir des
dictionnaires mais c'est vrai qu'on voit
de plus en plus de gens qui demandent le
bénéfice de l'aide juridictionnelle et
donc des services non les annonces de
l'assistance que nombre de l'assistance
c'est inquiétant mais je trouve qu'il
faut absolument pas ce faux pas ses
habitudes du tout dans jal bah oui oui
c'est bien évidemment fait que son jeu
c'est horrible tout le monde a le même
discours c'est longueur on ne peut pas
se contenter de ces chiffres qui
grandissent de cette précarité etc
après le seul point positif c'est que un
nombre de bénévoles absolument grève le
système fonctionne qui était pas la
séance monsieur ça que je mette en avant
parce que effectivement bon je dis on
pourrait gloser pendant des heures sur
sur la situation de l'économie
la précarité mais ce qui est génial
c'est cette analyse de la lyre excès
d'enthousiasmé cette solidarité de tous
les occupants une fois positif après ça
je trouve ça génial listera c'est ce que
jean schram bien dire en fait c'est un
gros merci je me suis dit finalement
merci mais non finalement et suivants de
la bouffe n'est pas un prétexte pour le
coup arrêté c'est une nécessité mais
pour le coup tous ces gens qui sont
autour ce que ça serait pas les derniers
à vouloir que ça s'arrête parce que ça
les occupe ce qui provenait que le monde
associatif à bord n'existe donc c'était
assez ignoble a annoncé nick c'est juste
que c'est juste que ça pour bien
préparer vos logos comme associatif
existe qu'il est vivant et qu'il se
retrouve dans cette tendance aux assauts
du coeur ils se retrouvent dans d'autres
associations j'ai moi même créé pharma
citoyens les pharmas citoyens récupère
du matériel médical des médicaments des
fauteuils roulants non pas de
médicaments rien de rien n'a jamais
uniquement des fauteuils roulants des
orthèses des prothèses pour des gens qui
sont vraiment au parc des princes la
mutuelle et à qui on peut donner ce type
de matériel donc c'est une c'est la même
forme et on a tous ces bénévoles qui
autour gravitent autour de l'association
dès lors qu'on les retrouve on les
retrouve dans le football également donc
bien sûr ses fonctions uniques de ma
part mais ça voulait dire ça c'est à
dire que j'ai vraiment il y sont
attachées aussi et c'est aussi un trait
du 2
française on est dans une phase était
quand même assez solide track s'amuser
les associations de plus en plus de mal
à recruter des bénévoles attend
peut-être même la sueur du caire on fire
il vaut mieux ils ont envahi les amener
à malleray au bénévolat est un dessin
d'humour qui va faire plaisir à notre
ami jean claude change évidemment change
que nous donnerons l'entrée d'un
restaurant et marquer restos du coeur et
puis il y avait le maître d'hôtel qui
étaient là et qui qui criait de vers la
vers la salle devant une table pour 8
millions cinq cent des gens mais vous
avez vous pensé qu'on pourrait avoir
peut-être une solution
oui justement d'abord l'europe aussi
tirer le tapis sous les associations ils
ont non elle est revenue armée abords
des collèges visionnaire moi je trouve
ça qu'un mec sans dire que ce bonhomme
qui aurait mérité d'être président de la
république à la place de bien d'autres
zadi de leur est pas un moment oui oui
oui donc visionnaires vous avez remarqué
que ces sketches n'ont pas pris une ride
ecoutez-le sur la société le chômage ça
mais alors quand même vraiment il ya des
sketches qui n'ont pas pris une ride et
puis enfin sur la précarité et la
pauvreté aujourd'hui ce sens avant il ya
une solution simple il ya du travail
chez nous plein moi je vois j'ai une
modeste entreprise où j'ai dix salariés
le salaire moyen de miss 10 salariés
ces 1500 euros net ça fait 3000 euros de
charges pour l'entreprise par dix a fait
trente mille euros par mois par 12 ça
fait vous avez compris 360 mille euros
eh bien faites un calcul simple
réduisez les charges patronales et les
charges salariales
juste ce qu'il faut pour qu'il
évidemment nous puissions payer quand
même nos assurances maladie vieillesse
et je vous assure je vous assure que
demain matin pour ce qui me concerne je
suis prêt à engager trois personnes à
condition que je reste avec la charge de
salaire identique même un peu supérieur
m dès lors que je puisse donner à mes
salariés plus vous en pincez moi je rêve
j'embaucherai évidemment et là moi sur
dix salariés j'en prends trois de plus à
venir pour cent le choix est simple si
vous je vais peu
je les trouverai on va pas faire le
débat là dessus c'est trop long mais oui
on peut les trouver on peut donner du
coup un emploi si m absolument c'est
quoi c'est pour moi deux chômeurs à
engager demain et un fonctionnaire tout
le monde sait aujourd'hui qu'il ya à peu
près un million et demi à 2 millions de
fonctionnaires de trop dans ce pays
notamment dans les collectivités
territoriales
non non non les fonctionnaires ne savent
aussi et surtout les hommes
politiquement personne n'ose le dire ce
qui est bien dommage
heureusement mon cher patrice tu as
inventé la télévision libre merci à toi
assuré je peux t'assurer attendent
demain matin demain on peut faire ça
alors j'ai moi des tableaux des éléments
très concrets de chiffres est mal posée
essayer de les publier sur internet
d'envoyer mais je t'assure qu'on peut
créer le plein on peut dans ce pays sans
aucun souci à condition évidemment que
les politiques soient courageux et
qu'effectivement comme le dit noureddine
nous nous remettions avec l'envi de
l'effort plutôt que celui de
l'assistanat c'est un changement de
société
mais nous sommes capables d'y arriver la
france a démontré au fur et à mesure de
son histoire qu'elle est capable de
changer de société et de changer de
monture un peu simpliste en attendant
défago sont un peu plus compliquées
les tableaux sur internet des données de
voilà des éléments du débat puisque vous
parlez de politique je lui que c'est une
élection c'est samedi soir enfin samedi
l'élection du futur dirigeant de l'ump
on avait la compagne de sarkozy
visiblement en bourse ça patine ça prend
pas il
il commence à s'énerver il y avait un
bon nom mais les sarkozy est très fort
j'ai toujours dit à mes amis qui
hurlaient quand je disais sarkozy c'est
peut-être le meilleur d'entre nous donc
vous avez certainement entendu les
récentes polémiques avec rachida dati
parce que voilà ce que ça algériens et
marocains
donc on bâtit d'un koné la formulation
est exceptionnel la formulation comme
pour dire à moi je trouve ça formidable
terme de condom
c'est vicieux je trouve ça formidable
puisque du coup depuis hier on ne parle
que de ça et sarkozy a réussi à se
remettre au centre du débat
on ne parle plus que de sarkozy on a
oublié mariton on a oublié le maire le
maire je viens de dire finalement
j'étais de m'allier avec ça non c'est là
la force de nicolas sarkozy que c'est
très fort parce que je lisais je croise
dans le nouvel obs et c'est certes c'est
un de ses proches qui dit voilà mais en
fait il est revenu mais salon merde
comme ça m'emmerde
il est mauvais comme il est mort il
s'énerve et comme il s'était fait des
conneries mais si c'est un mauvais qui
garde la présidence de l'ue elle ça me
paraissait assez ça me paraissait pas eu
mais là faut pas aidé mais bon il est
probable qu'ils s'ennuient un petit peu
parce qu'un type qui était président de
la hausse avec quoi qu'on en pense c'est
vrai pour l'instant il n'est pas
dévoilée et la salle et même occupé
naguère dit qu'il a eu pendant cinq ans
donc ça c'est pas très grave après c'est
vrai que le pot pour la campagne il fait
une campagne qui est moins bonne en tout
cas moins tonitruante qu'on avait pu
imaginer moins facile aussi c'est moins
facile puisque est intéressant chaud
dans la campagne c'est que le maire
s'est un peu révélé ce voeu paraît être
un type qui en a vraiment sous le pied
et puis si vraiment il s'allie après
avec sarkozy pourquoi pas ça peut faire
quelque chose de très intéressant donc
moi je faisais plutôt bien et c'est une
campagne plutôt plutôt ça nous fait j'ai
laissé ça rien passé d'extraordinaire
seront discutées arrêté un vieux débat
je ne sais pas moi même j'ai
l'impression que yade comme une
déchirure dérive la droite qu'on est
avec aujourd'hui 2 droite républicaine à
mon avis qui aura peut-être deux
candidats à la présidentielle on sait
jamais il peut diriger la lutte entre
alain juppé et sa liberté d'alain juppé
sifflé dans son fief frais à bord
d'autres que moi je trouve pas que c'est
formidable mais sûrement pas pour la
droite sur quoi il a été sifflé
justement son rôle rassemblement de la
zone afrique à placer le sont avec le
centre non mais c'est sacré et gratter j
c'est pour ça que ça y est de droite sur
la façon des primaires c'est le truc le
plus débile qu'on puisse imaginer
je repars droite comme à gauche à chaque
fois je veux dire sa force les gens d'un
même parti à s'engueuler réseau gsm à
faire c'est absolument tragique on a vu
à gauche que ça a donné
on veut pas dire que ces deux meilleurs
candidats enfin en tout cas le meilleur
président et à droite voilà ils sont
tous en train de se tirer dessus à deux
projets différents jallarbistes s'adonne
l'ail et leurs produits à travers le
sort pourrait plus côté droit un jour
j'ai de juppé on verra mais je sais
aussi qu'il ya trois mois la nouveauté
une tradition quand même eu la france
bref voilà j'ai pas été si fort que ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup j'ai pas trouvé
ça très incomplet passionnant j'ai pas
trouvé ça passionnant j'ai retrouvé
sarkozy allait effectivement agité
détestable comme il sait l'être quand il
est détestable en même temps c'est celui
qui arrive effectivement par des coups
de com a harangué les faux là c'est un
peu le gourou avec ce qu'on ressent il
ya un gourou et puis des adeptes qui
sont soit élu le débat ça va être
quel va être le pourcentage pour lui
est-ce qu'il est élu à 80 pays les usa
et qu'est ce qu'il va se passer donc
j'ai pas trouvé ça très très près
palpitant je trouve ça pitoyable que
j'ai passées à bordeaux et surtout ce
que j'ai trouvé pitoyable ans que les
gens sifflent parce que ils n'ont pas
oublié que berrou avait appelé à voter
pour hollande et c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont sifflés mais j'ai trouvé pitoyable
que sarkozy bouge pas de son fauteuil ne
fasse rien ne bouge pas de discours
rédigé pas attendu alors s'arrêter un
ornement vous mets ça sur canal en
affaires que vous qu'ils interviennent
ces débats devant des millions d'êtres
bien
au même titre qu'il a cédé sur
l'abrogation danse writing précieux dans
une démocratie
alors quand les militants sont comme des
béni oui oui tout le monde dit c'est
ridicule ces masses de gens qui sont là
à se lever pour applaudir a fait
redescendre innover chaîne et quand ils
expriment un avis on dit c'est
scandaleux
j'ai pas dit que c'était son allure
générale le jeudi qu'il ne pouvait
siffler sa ison boîte c'est ce que j'ai
trouvé scandaleux ces telle attitude de
sartilly
où sont passées de la sicile la
bienvenue rivés sur sa campagne autre
temps qui pouvait rassembler intervenus
on aurait dit benoît ils seront déjà
pour le cheikh ben ghazi les a perdu
jusqu'à ce qu'il dirige qu'est ce qu'ils
disent justement il dit ok pour un
rassemblement avec le centre mais si le
centre est avec nous le matin le midi et
le soir et pas par intermittence donc il
lui répond directement à la jupe est
effectivement il lui là il va dans le
sens de ce que la salle dit aussi des
petits sifflet exactement ils sont
devant des militants c'est pas
représentative de la france excusez moi
ce que ça m'évoque c'est que pour le
coup il ya beaucoup de com il ya
beaucoup de stratégie bon c'est de la
politique politicienne
ça fait partie de la politique on est
d'accord simplement moi je le regarde et
je me rends compte que finalement
l'objectif est atteint c'est d'arriver à
ce que tous les plateaux de télé dans
toutes les familles dans tous les bars
on parle de légumes et qu'on parle pas
de l'essentiel et pour le coup
l'essentiel peut-être évalue que
peut-être que les six heures peut-être
que l'essentiel ça serait éventuellement
de masquer les affaires parce que dans
cette histoire mais au départ j'ai
vraiment cru qu'ils pourraient même pas
se présenter
j'ai presque envie de dire à une mairie
un département une région parce que type
d'affaires qui là j'ai pensé aux
quelques uns quelqu'un est jeune et je
dis probablement probablement que je ne
me serais pas présenté avec eux une
affaire et là pour le coup il se
présente pour le coup d'abord à l'ump
aux présidentielles ensuite mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya un élément dont on parle
le pain c'est ça et dont on ne parle
plus les enfants en show que je laime
d'affaires et sur la les 5-6 affaire
dont on parle
je crois qu'il y en a très peu dans
lesquelles il est vraiment mis en examen
donc bon mais je pense que le problème
l'annoncé de moi je vois pas le fond et
c'est quoi le projet politique nous quel
est le projet politique pour 2017
les primaires ça bien mal m'en porte on
n'a pas eu le moindre soupçon sur un
homme politique on parlait tout à
l'heure du footballeur qui est
exemplaire pour les enfants du foot je
pense que pour les politiques pour pas
simplement les enfants et pour les
adultes
je pense qu'on doit être aussi
exemplaire moi je dis pas qu'il ya
quelque chose
j'ai simplement qu'on a pris un panda
pris l'habitude en france rencontre que
le moindre soupçon te fasse sortir la
vie politique pour te laver de tout
soupçon pour le coup et revenir blanchi
pour le coup j'en suis d'accord
elle sait pas le formel à la présidence
tout ça est ridicule
désolé pour tous les hommes politiques
que ce soit george tron eric woerth etc
ont été obligés de quitter leur
ministère de tutelle
il y en a eu aussi à gauche a donné des
noms d'hommes politiques qui sont dont
l'un carrière ruinée après il ya non
lieu sûr non lieu c'est lamentable
lambeaux et c'est lamentable l'emploi
seront ils étaient complètement lavé de
tous et le devis et la péruse ministère
il ya eu un coup de tête
là il ya surtout de tout soupçon on
parle des avocats après mais un mot sur
est-ce que vous avez suivi la campagne
anglaise devrait réserver leur mesure
ces livres là pour ça ça me touche un
peu mais ça s'appelle des kiss and tell
c'est bien on voit s'embrasser rapide du
moment culturel est ce qu'elle
représente les femmes votre billet très
intéressant
enfin voilà son bouquin est totalement
inintéressant sens que enfin moi je
serai enfin j'avais besoin de lire un
bouquin d'une ado kwa ces maisons mais à
oui enfin qu'elle soit blessée choix
elle s'est fait jeter de façon quasi
nationale nationale sur les que ça porte
atteinte au fond la france à la
présidence j'ai deux filles mariées avec
deux gendarmes tués - adorable déjà deux
petites filles et les moutons sur cinq
petits enfants
je souhaite vraiment que nîmes et fille
ni mes petites filles ne tombe sur un
bonhomme comme celui sur lequel est
tombé madame triangulaire alors
maintenant son sentiment de revanche
vraiment j'approuve parce que je suis
désolé il doit y avoir un respect mutuel
et la madame trillard bel air avec
alassane y aura donc beaucoup qui rêvent
peut respecter à bas après coup bah tant
pis les risques sont pris après quand tu
es les pots cassés
il ya des pots cassés amis quand valérie
trierweiler a viré ségolène royal elle
n'était pas effondré a pas d'accord à la
compassion et par la gentillerie fallu
que monsieur hollande qui avait fait
quatre enfants madame royal se marient
avis demande le mariage
évidemment à vous êtes président de la
république pour la première fois qu'il
n'est pas marié si je dis pas de bêtises
de rayssac à l'épreuve
mais mais pas assez au pad pannes sont
assez inquiets maintenant
du coup à peut-être les fous les
françaises ont battu avoir des mariages
qui se sont prolongés alors qu'il
n'existait pas dans les faits oui moi je
crie qu'il est une vertu pour moi ce
bouquin il a la vertu de barbarie
non je parle je parle pas je parle pas
de lui même je pars de la campagne sert
qu'à se représenter elle a présenté son
livre en angleterre et probablement
qu'elle ira en italie et dans d'autres
pays
on a ces faits donc voyez il ya là il ya
une vertu moi je pense que c'est un peu
comme toutes les stars
quand les stars sont atteintes d'un
cancer elles ont une couverture
médiatique faramineuses ils peuvent
parler de cette maladie et où quelqu'un
les gens se reconnaissent
et là j'ai l'impression qu'elle parle de
la maladie d'amour d'une part c'est le
vertueux j'ai pas dit j'ai pas dit j'ai
pas dit j'ai pas dit que ça n'avait pas
un caractère de vengeance j'ai pas du
tout le reste mais on l'a déjà dit trop
souvent je trouve qu'on tire un peu trop
fort aussi moi la seule chose qui me
gêne dans quel sens là c'est quoi la
madeleine merci on va passer à un autre
sujet parce que j'aimerais qu'on en
parle c'est justement est ce que c'est
la révolte des nordistes et les avocats
étaient dans la rue cette semaine alors
j'évite toute allergie du salaire que le
même pas d aller dans la rue non mais
les patrons ont peut-être réfléchir au
fait d'aller eux aussi manifester vous
regarde
un sujet vous étiez à versailles avec
des avocats dans la rue on regarde le
sujet on en parle tout de suite après ce
moment est un moment espéré pour la
profession plus qu'un ver salle est
rassemblée aujourd'hui la quasi-totalité
des barreaux d'ile-de-france nanterre
versailles charte essonne val de marne
ou encore pontoise la plupart des
avocats des barreaux d'île de france a
fait le déplacement ce matin
en ligne de mire la réforme macron et la
création d'un statut d'avocat
d'entreprise et l'introduction de
capitaux
ce que les avocats voit comme une caméra
dépendance de leur profession on a le
sentiment de ne pas être entendus
effectivement quand on a un ministre de
l'économie qui légifère pour la justice
c'est vrai que c'est quand même c'est
voilà c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
acceptable pour nous il n'est pas dans
l'habitude des avocats de faire grève
un avocat ça travaille 70 heures par
semaine c'est pas son style de vie que
de faire grève
on n'est pas là pour battre le pavé on
est là pour plaider sommes là pour
défendre à si on l'a fait c'est vraiment
parce qu'on avait le sentiment que le
justiciable était au coeur hauteur
réelle du problème
alors pour se faire entendre une semaine
d'actions a été fait
cette manifestation intervient après une
grève et plusieurs suspensions
d'audience puisque les avocats
demandaient les renvois qui est pas
d'avocat des magistrats digne de ce nom
n'ont pas voulu prendre les dossiers
donc ça veut dire que pendant 48 heures
ces deux semaines il n'y a pas une
justice dans la quasi totalité de la
france
nous avons constaté que nous avions un
accueil favorable de très haut magistrat
est ce qu est un véritable malheur dans
ce pays c'est que c'est aux magistrats
ne sont même pas consulté sur cette
réforme les avocats ne compte pas
s'arrêter là
la mobilisation devrait continuer la
semaine prochaine s'ils n'obtiennent pas
satisfaction
alors cette révolte cette marche des
avocats est pourquoi pour pour quelle
raison le projet de jeu laissait le
projet macro inquiets du projet oui
alors faut d'abord commencer par dire
que 1 notre profession on n'a pas de
numerus clausus c'est à dire qu'on
pourrait avoir 150 cabinets d'avocats
qui s'installe à montigny ce serait
stupide mais il n'y a pas de numéro se
fait aussi il y avait un concours comme
pour être médecin praticien pour voilà
on passe un concours il n'y a pas de
numéro de closer et tout le monde peut
s'installer à s'installer où il veut
mais il faut le projet macron c'est
quand même un projet pour la liberté de
la concurrence et redonner du pouvoir
d'achat
ce sont les lignes du projet macron moi
ce qui m'étonne en premier lieu c'est ce
que disait une de mes concerts dans le
dans l'interview c'est que notre
profession pour la réforme et est porté
par bercy alors ministre des finances
par le ministère de la justice
donc on voit que la ligne qui est porté
en facialement et de façon ouverte c'est
une ligne économique et financière c'est
par exemple ces trois axes voilà ces
trois axes la réforme c'est la
postulation la postulation c'est que
pour tous les les affaires qui sont
devant le tribunal de grande instance
les parties doivent être représentés par
un avocat du barreau de ce tribunal
jeunes un exemple vous voulez divorcé
devant le tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
vous pouvez avoir un avocat de paris
mais vous devez avoir un représentant
local versailles aujourd'hui c'est de ça
que ça se passe
le projet prévoit à ce que la
postulation ne soit pas sur le tribunal
mais soit au niveau de la cour d'appel
est dans la cour d'appel on a plusieurs
tribunaux qui relève d'une même pour
d'appel donc ça veut dire qu'on va
ouvrir la population et faire une
multipostulation ce contre quoi
les avocats se révoltent par rapport à
ce point là c'est que dans un certain
nombre de tribunaux de province je pense
que c'est plutôt les cabinets d'avocats
de province qui vont être touchés c'est
qu'il ya des petits cabinets qui vivent
de ces postulation là en disant voilà on
a je peux avoir un procès avant vous
avez un procès avant voudra vannes par
dont vous devez prendre un avocat de
gran votre avocat être paris vous avez
un représentant à vannes qui connaît le
tribunal qui connaît les juges qui sait
si on a voilà c'est quand moi non mais
c'est bien je lui dise non mais je suis
justiciables je comprends très bien
prendre du justiciable si ce n'est que
là c'est par rapport à notre profession
je suis bien d'accord c'est que tous ces
petits cabinets là vont fermer boutiques
parce que je sais c'est la fin c'est la
fin des avocats de proximité et sarre
boucle par le deuxième axe de la loi
macro qui l'ouverture du capital d
société avocat aujourd'hui on ne peuvent
être associé d'un cabinet d'avocats que
des avocats
là il ouvre à tout le monde sauf aux
banques et aux assurances pourquoi par
les banques et par les assurances pour
préserver l'indépendance parce que non a
dit nos valeurs en tant que média
investisseurs se sont peu à voir des
business angels de la famille on peut
avoir des experts comptables on peut
avoir des commissariats
alors là où moi j'y vois un problème
c'est par rapport à d'autres
indépendance si dans la majorité du
capital est détenue majoritairement par
des commissaires aux comptes ou des
experts comptables ou vous allez avoir
des comptes à rendre à vos actionnaires
ce qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui on n'a pas
de compte à rendre à nos actionnaires
on est complètement indépendants
professions libérales ça s'appelle une
profession libérale et notre
indépendance ont nié farouchement
attachés et cette problème d'ouverture
de capital quand je termine avant
l'ouverture du capital
voilà fait que donc on va avoir plus de
20 au capital et surtout ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir des regroupements et
pourquoi ouverture de capital c'est pour
permettre éventuellement à des experts
comptables d'autres avec des avocats ce
qui est très bien de faire des sociétés
où on va mutualiser tous les week-ends
société à l'américaine mais ça veut dire
que là aussi on tue les petits cabinets
individuel dire que les petits cabine
habituel yvon ni vont perdre
effectivement toutes ces problématiques
de postulation bon maintenant c'est à
moi mon avis c'est pas un bon débarras
l'histoire la postulation mais ils vont
aussi perdre la proximité et l'accès au
droit
que dire qu'il ya des cabinets dans des
petites villes qui vont fermer parce
qu'ils ont plus de clients qui vont
partir sur des gros énorme structure au
niveau des cours d'appel et c'est un
soleil et le troisième c'est le statut
la création du statut d'avocat en
entreprise
c'est ça alors là gilet noir reste alors
qu'elle est un juriste d'entreprise peut
devenir avocat il n'a pas le droit de
plaider pour son employeur puisque
l'avocat en question sera salariés il
n'aura pas le droit de plaider pour son
employeur le seul intérêt du statut
d'avocat c'est le secret professionnel
c'est à dire que tout ce que l'avocat
pourra écrire dans son entreprise auprès
des autres services sera protégé par le
par le secret et la confidentialité donc
pas mal vis-à-vis de l'urssaf vis-à-vis
du fisc vis-à-vis
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer mais par
rapport à l'indépendance de l'avocat
parce que ça statut à part
il n'a pas le même statut que nous
savons que ce sera un avocat mais c'est
à nouveau statut donc ce ne sera pas le
même que de notre ce nous on ne dépend
que du bâtonnier là s'il a un problème
dans son emploi il va au conseil des
prud'hommes donc on voit bien que c'est
un statut complètement différent et donc
par rapport à l'indépendance ça me pose
un problème parce qu'il reçoit quand
même désordre de son employeur pour
lequel il travaille à 100%
il ne peut pas leur présenter devant un
tribunal ce qui montre bien qu'il ya un
problème d'indépendance et derrière sur
la confidentialité les écrits qui va
écrire avec si on fait des transactions
de négociations il va écrire des avocats
extérieurs nous tout ça est couvert par
le secret professionnel
sauf que là il pourra pas opposé son
secret professionnel puisque c'est dans
la halle le projet de loi à son
employeur aura accès donc on va violer à
mon avis toutes nos valeurs
d'indépendance de secret professionnel
et je pense que là le justiciable a tout
à y perdre avec une problématique
d'accès au droit est avec une
dégradation des conditions douala pour
vous pensez vous parce que je pense
qu'elle est bonne celle qui ferait j'ai
plutôt l'impression que c'est une
défense corporatiste que des photos vous
avez peut-être raison
qu'est ce qu'on en pensait et alors
attendez juste une chose on n'est pas
des nantis au niveau du barreau de
versailles
50% des avocats gagnent moins de 1400
euros par mois et sur ces cinq ne sais
pas ce que c'est fait je désire 5400
euros par mois et sur ses 50% sur ses
cinq membres mon coeur la cia j'ai dit
au barreau de versailles baroda et à
paris c'est à peu près pareil 50%
gagnent moins de 1400 euros et sur ses
50% qui gagnent moins de 1400 euros la
moitié gagnent moins de 800 euros par
contre que parfois ça serait bientôt
proposé avoir des gros actionnaires ont
dit non alors à savoir et non pas dans
les pièces cabine un mot
oui alors ça va vous êtes concerné vous
parlez lentilles aussi ouais alors je ne
suis pas concerné par ce par le même
débat mort l'été par la même cause c'est
à dire que on veut ouvrir sur des
professions dites libérales en gros on
veut des idées réglementé des
professions comme la vôtre et comme la
nôtre sauf que j'ai le sentiment qu'ils
aient des techniques en politique qui
consiste à dire je vais vous coupez les
deux bras et au final vous serez très
heureuse qu'on vous en coûte qu'un seul
donc là on a effectivement agiter un
chiffon rouge war 2 la bande des
médicaments voilà et pour le pour les
pharmaciens c'est la même chose à faire
quand on dit on va laisser rentrer
médicaments et grandes surfaces
on va laisser rentrer le capital est
donc avec tout ça on a les mêmes
argumentaires qu'on retrouve exactement
la même dialectique
sauf que moi j'ai pas trop envie d'en
dire sur la défense de la profession
elles se défendent plutôt plutôt bien en
même temps il ya quand même une volonté
à revoir
il ya comme une volonté aussi ces deux
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat donc ça
on en parle probablement que c'est en
partie vrai parce que le leur il est
aussi là c'est de dire que c'est aussi
pour le contribuable et pour le
consommateur mais qu'il a payé - sauf
qu'il le paiera différemment d'accord
mais deuxième pari des parts dans son
mémoire et n'ayez rien une chose qui me
frappe c'est à dire que vous êtes les
premiers à dire faut moderniser voilà
s'il savait faux est déco s'attaque à
vous dites oh la la
tous ont rien fait mais la difficulté
c'est normal à une fois c'est un peu
sympa vrai nom mais ce qui nous a
choqués nous au niveau de notre
profession c'est que ce soit bercy qui
part avec la grosse cavalerie sens en
négociation il n'y a pas il ya pas de
s'éterniser la société je dire si on est
dehors dans la rue c'est qu'il n'y a pas
eu de concertation et qui nous a là
c'est d'abord il y avait un projet qui a
été on a retiré le statut en entreprise
parce que la commission des lois dit oui
ouhlala niveau de l'indépendance est un
problème
et puis dans d'autres dont ils le
remettent et l'envoie au conseil d'état
tel quel donc si la terre parce qu'il te
reste trois minutes je vais entendre ce
que je cherche pas des fonds de la
pression pour la profession elle se
défend très bien je n'y allais pas ton
patata qu'est que ça sauf que il ya des
choses je ne constate quand même que
l'entraidé que les gens sont concernés
disent oh
les panneaux à l'entrée ou l'entrée au
capital d'étrangers la profession c'est
une chose mais par exemple pour les
pharmaciens il est question d'ouvrir le
capital aux pharmaciens qui resteraient
finalement entre eux et finalement
l'entrée du capital c'est aussi une
manière de financer des choses que
l'état ne peut plus permettre de
financer tout en gardant un service de
qualité
verdict le constat qu'on peut faire je
le fais à chaque fois que j'ai
l'occasion de pouvoir en parler c'est la
faiblesse des corps intermédiaires
ça veut dire que dans ce pays nous
sommes pas capables de créer des corps
intermédiaires suffisamment puissant
crédible pour pouvoir faire face aux
administrations et aux pouvoirs tous les
autres pays d'europe du nord par exemple
vont vers des consensus grâce à
l'existence de corps intermédiaires
crédible et puissant nous ne sommes pas
foutu de faire ça dans ce pays il est
grand temps d'améliorer cette situation
c'est valable pour les avocats
préformation pour les restaurateurs pour
les journalistes pour tout le monde
absence de crédibilité et de puissance
des contrats derrière ces dangereuses
grâce à moi la première chose c'est que
c'est pas du tout persuadé qu'une
réforme portée par taubira serait plus
intelligente et plus saines
donc ça c'est ça la donc temps là je
pars mais de les junies parle business
ça c'est la première chose et après ce
qui me choque au au delà peut-être du
fait que les avocats auraient peut-être
pu se réveiller avant qu'on les
comprenne qu'on propose de le réformer
leurs preuves
leur profession et qu'on l'a règlement
de façon différente les screens qui me
choque un petit peu c'est que
politiquement tout ça est quand même un
peu une politique de bouc émissaire
terre qu'on dit que les pharmaciens sont
des nantis que les avocats sont des
nantis indiquent tous ces gens là sont
des nantis et pendant ce temps là c'est
un peu comme quand on attaque les grands
patrons d un énorme salaire
du coup on focalise sur l'énorme salaire
du nifff en oubliant clés de l'équipe
sont sous payés aux opa du truc c'est
une politique de bouc émissaire qui rime
pas à grand chose
et très honnêtement je pense qu'en
france la priorité c'est pas rimer cgem
après leur belle arrêté en france avec 5
millions de chômeurs c'est pas de savoir
si on peut investir dans un cabinet
d'avocat ou si on peut investir dans une
pharmacie franchement c'est sale et tout
a été dit je pense
bon rien d'autre à juin soit juste un
petit mot pour finir
est ce que le
la caisse juste une question est ce que
le droit est un produit de consommation
est ce que vous êtes pour le gel des
salaires et le médicament pour le gel
des salaires
bon je suis pas particulièrement pour le
gel des salaires jusqu'à de qui de quoi
ddd des salariés des propositions mais
non des salaires si on a une activité
qui marche bien faut augmenter les
salaires des propositions l epad pas
formulé comme ça mais du rapport ferry
qui était au mit à maquereau c'est une
dénonciation l'argent et que en effet
économiquement probablement mais
philosophiquement nous faisons bryson
mais comme c'est un point mérité sa
fille voilà mais sinon dans une
entreprise si l'entreprise marché
salaire chacun chacun gère sa boîte
comme il veut dire si l'argent rentré
que le boulot est bien fait on a
beaucoup parlé des mouvements au medef
il faut quand même savoir que le
mouvement qui est en train de se mettre
en route actuellement faute d'ailleurs
de crédibilité des cosaques de me dire
là encore regroupe le medef la cgpme et
juppé à ses trésors les patrons des
salaires malheureusement malheureusement
on parle que du medef ce qui est bien
dommage pour le medef dans l'image
populaire est pas représentatif
réellement s'agit pas bella ouais bon
pour imaginer des raies sûr mais en lan
le mouvement qui est en route à l'égard
des patrons c'est le medef plus la cgpme
plus occupés à c'est important de le
signaler
surtout que les actions sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes si on penche non non non
non non il faut qu'on arrête mais on
reprendra la prochaine fois mais les
gens parce que c'est des sujets sur
lesquels on aura beau autre débat
évidemment
merci à tous les cinq
c'est ça que j'aime bien quand il ya des
mouvements ya moi je m'appelle pousse ma
femme s'appelle alain jeanroy c'est pas
au niger merci à tous et à très vite
pour un nouveau parfum